if you have a triangle with its base as
b and height as h then we know that its
area is one half times b times h
but how did we get this
let's see
here's our triangle abc now let's draw
congruent triangle here and then we
place it here
we will name this point d
so both the triangles are congruent to
each other it means both the triangles
are the same
now if we move this part and keep it
here
then what shape will we get
correct we get a rectangle with height h
and base b
so what is the area of a rectangle
correct it's b times h it means the area
of both the triangles together is b
times h
and because the triangles are congruent
the area of one triangle will be base
multiplied by height divided by two
this way we get the formula of a
triangle if you liked our video then
please hit the like button and for more
such interesting math concepts do
subscribe to our youtube channel
you